like to see bald man movement
involvement this Bulls team is too good
defensively for you to try to challenge
them but a direct one-on-one game throws
it down on a beautiful cut Mozgov
founded cut but excellent pass by Mozgov
you may want to back off of him to
protect against those tests Rhodes knows
the Tucker with two MVPs guarding each
other fill the bowls back up by three
rolls is still a rose by any other name
knock down step back jump shot a thing
of beauty
Thompson calling for it against Dunleavy
most has been given up Smith and some
prey JR Smith with his second
three-pointer to Tyler gave that words
the Lisa Salters now the soul of not
come back in the game a left answering
string Butler's jumper packs it in and
we can tell him to sort out something is
bothering them to be tied against five
and a half remaining Butler's fires the
three
but today Kevin buckler for this first
three-pointer of the night help take
away the roll to the rim and keep body
on body Rose lost affection
you know 62
knocks it down
and I thought that was a good decision
by James games while I was with Cutler
settles for the jumper and rattles it in
it's a one-point game
James cookie find [ __ ] fighters of grade
ESCA JR Smith Creek downtown ties it
again into offensive purposes but their
drives mutlar gets inside stops layup is
good
great adjustment from Butler in the boat
back to port
timeout Cleveland the screen mike
dunleavy they're trying to set a screen
for him he's not open great balance and
pivot move my Butler against jr. Smith
[Applause]
if you make a great morning coach now
you you go two for one it's 33 it
changes up to the ball game the great
thing about this is the plate has been
so quick I'm not going to
looking back to Smith
[Applause]
ties the game with
seconds remaining wookies finds rose
rose trying to get open fire boys
god
so much
[Applause]
so fortunate very fortunate